do you know why i'm unstoppable
because i only control what i can
control and don't care about all the
things i want this portion is like with
me so i think this is when you need to
get selfish like you need to ask your
question
[Music]
hiring is guessing firing is knowing
like you got to go fast that's how you
get [ __ ] done that's how you figure
stuff out this is the television
and the television is the
radio the 40s [ __ ]
real pleasure to be with everybody let's
rock and roll let's rock and roll let's
start with elita i'm going to go ahead
and spotlight you guys and start the
timer go ahead alita
all right cool
all right so gary um the first
thing
that i wanted to ask you was um
well i might start with the question
before i go into any context
i wanted to ask you what pre-launch or
launch insights you thought creators
might need most or the businesses
working with the businesses working with
creators will need in order to sort of
best serve them
um in order to launch projects and
maintain them over the long term so one
of the first tools that we've built is
um like a rarity and trait design
sandbox
and this um
allows creators to
um you know it visualizes their rarity
as it will look on open c um it makes
sure the res will look rare you can
check for mislabeled traits spelling
mistakes it flags metadata issues and
basically it's this in platform guidance
on rarity design it's a free tool that
creators are already using and it's in
beta i like that um
the other tools that we've um started to
build for creators are around community
and marketing analytics tools because we
really feel like that's going to be
really powerful
for creators like identifying
communities with strong overlap to find
collaboration opportunities um discord
insight so like highlighting key events
like
highlighting messages users are engaging
with sentiment shift alerts
lots of there's a lot we can do with the
community data that we have
um
so i'm just wondering from your
perspective what you think
would be most valuable
the the um obviously the first thing you
mentioned is really around the creation
of project and the free launch yeah and
the second is
hopefully as it gets smart the ability
to predict
successful
opportunities or even success outright i
mean i think the the biggest thing that
so the timing
of this all is interesting because
we're now going into the next phase of
nft land where
just because you have an nft doesn't
mean you're going to be successful
and
that is exciting for me because it
becomes a more mature
set
anything you can do
to help
creators
realize
that they have to actually build demand
is the biggest thing you can help them
with
people think that they have a thousand
people in the discord
and they're all gonna buy the project
you know what i mean like there's so
much naivete from project creators right
now
yeah so anything that can indicate depth
is the most interesting data in my
opinion
yeah so you know i think being able to
maybe being able to know who your
holders are know who you like your most
active community members are what who
what other projects are your holders
holding like
who is that the
the problem with just math is as you can
imagine what projects your holders or
hold you know your community is holding
is good data but if you don't overlay
that to the moment in the marketplace
we're at the data can be incredibly
dirty very quickly so i would say
much like you're helping people rarity
score and things of that nature helping
people
understand more context of the reality
of the community and
maybe even maybe even give them training
wheels to create intent
uh based metrics might be a really good
idea
um
all right
that's helpful um
so
the other question i had is
um
so one of the first things i'm going to
be doing when we on stealth is make this
contextual creative content that we've
been talking about all day or night in
my case
um and i want the content to be targeted
and when i think about the demographics
we're targeting i believe it starts with
sort of nft native first and then crypto
native second and then everyone else but
targeting everyone else when you have no
brand yet is sort of really targeting no
one um and because we're building an nft
data platform
i feel like you know creators could
potentially be anybody from artists to
musicians to event organizers
yeah so i'm just like
trying to to work out who do we market
to first
um
i i think
the answer to that question is yes
[Laughter]
all about it and all of them early on to
then understand if there's traction or
nuances that make some
more interesting
i always laugh because people try to be
thoughtful especially when there's
engineering dna
yeah
they overthink
the value in the upfront you're building
a business you're going to get to
marketing to all of them over the next
four years
so does it really matter up front it
doesn't in the and as a matter of fact i
would argue that the widening net gives
you better signals to where there might
be opportunity
right
yeah that's right so you know don't
don't go too narrow and and the
my yeah my mind in the social media
world is is kind of as wide as one can
to taste but then you can narrow in you
know
um
so
what sort of messages will get the
attention of nft creators this is um
i think uh
yeah uh
content that speaks to
in web 2 there was things like hubspot
or google analytics or creating
historical reference points to make them
understand very quickly why your thing's
important to them on their journey is
big
historical reference points of what
happened in web 2
as a proxy to web 3 i think would work
really well for you
okay
um so
i'm aware obviously from listening to
you that
um you know a lot
a lot to do with linkedin and tick tock
for organic reach is like probably a
necessity
um i'm just wondering if you think
there's any essential platforms that i
should be considering using at scale
with ad dollars like should i be
considering going big on paid twitter
for example twitter yeah twitter and
discord as you know is where the market
is
and then i would do long tail
podcasts
there's so many twitter spaces you need
to become a beacon of the community
it's doing you know it's about
non-scalable behavior
mm-hmm
we were talking a little bit about
twitch earlier because her boyfriend
who's also the ceo is a big into the
gaming space and seems to think there's
a lot of like engineering types that
might overlap in that world do you think
that's a possibility i think it's a
possibility yeah yeah because we believe
like i mean a lot of the people that
will be using our tools will be the
engineer on the creative team
right yeah yes
ish
i think you're gonna if you're gonna
build a good tool you need to build it
for the middle and long tail
which will actually be
entrepreneurs with
engineered tendencies
yeah
meaning
capable
like the reason google adwords worked
going way back in history was i
could use it
yeah that's right and so like you need
it you need to be like an artist or a
project like a lot of them don't have
engineers
yeah right i mean that's why we've got
you know we're hiring like three front
end engineers to make it and product
managers to make it like highly well
that's usually
the reason i'm the reason i'm reacting
the way i am is everything up to the
point of that statement
made me feel that you were building
something more for mass
um because
as you know like
as you cross a chasm of engineering
they're they're going to have other
options if they're
an engineer
right they're going to they're going to
think through like do they want to do
their own apis like do they like you
know that where there's that middle
ground where it's switched over i think
twitter is the answer to your question
but i also think it's about you
and your boyfriend becoming pillars of
the nft community through discord and
twitter
right
yeah
got to get out of still awesome
yeah at some point you will and that'll
be great
we're gonna move along uh i'm gonna
bring up the uh folks from box bowling
uh we got the
brothers
victor and jacob so hey guys
hey guys again
big fans we've been following you for
years
thank you i'm gonna start with a short
video
[Music]
yeah i'm cutting it off there yep very
good yeah so
basically we want people to move and
have fun
um i'm gonna show you some slides from a
deck because it's easier for us to talk
about
so
we do gamified physical activity yep
competition games challenges and
workouts yep it's great tech startup we
gained some press yep we've been doing
three good years growing but we want to
grow so much more
skip that
people of all different ages make sense
small
yeah
everyone can use it
a product simple
uh we've been doing a breast cancer
charity we've donated 150 000
um the app we have different game modes
but this is really what me and my
brother want to do we want to be the
fastest growing sport in the world
even before pickleball and paddle and
everything why
be that's a good let's victor you take
it
i take it i mean i'm i come from soccer
i play soccer 20 years of football
i love the competitive competitiveness i
love the competitions and when i get to
see now we had an 11 year old win 12 000
and not not that i only win the money
but he got
he got to be a superstar yeah of course
you know he got interviewed by the
newspaper televisions yes we're like wow
you're number one in a sport i want
this to be the fastest growing sport
because i want to be able to see these
kids do this and love it but i think i'm
asking you guys out of because i think
you have something very good here i i'm
okay well actually let me put on a shelf
because i don't want to waste our time
on this yeah okay fine next go ahead no
but now you got me interesting
interested well i
because i think
when i look at your business even in
that quick chart that i saw there's two
things that scared me in the whole thing
so a couple things
it's very good what you have
it hits me on all the checkboxes i care
about the two things that concern me is
the sentence when you said but we want
to go faster
and the sentence that says and i want
this to be the number one fastest
growing
sport both of those are ideologies that
have nothing to do with anything
so why why the thing is everyone can use
this you can be in africa
that has nothing to do with anything you
two as the founders creating ideologies
for yourself
has the ability to impact the way you
operate the business
okay
so what i mean by that is
that's very nice but both of you know
this
fastest growing sport everyone's going
to use different data to claim they're
the fastest growing sport
we have the most new people
and what it means is that we want
a lot of user moving and playing with
the gold that good that sounds like a
good idea when you're building a
business you would like as many
customers as possible
yeah but also because we've seen the
happiness that it brings and
but there's happiness in a hundred
different things that people do
physically
people are happy when they play
pickleball when they run on the
treadmill when they work out in the gym
when they eat better like
what what's very important in business
in my opinion
is not letting
control too much of actions
meaning everything you're doing is right
and now you're at year three or four and
this is exactly when people start making
big mistakes
because they go into philosophy instead
of execution
okay and so we wanted
we wanted this since year one that's
beautiful so keep doing what you've been
doing
yeah
okay so the thing is you're saying that
we we shouldn't do it we shouldn't do it
faster
yeah exactly i think when you start like
anything that the fact that you even
mentioned pickleball is
bad let me explain what i mean i'll
explain
what you need to just be tunnel vision
on execution of expanding your thing
by mentioning pickleball you've already
let the philosophy of fastest growing
sport plus it's contextual to me i
understand where you're going but
but you should be razor focused on
customer acquisition and retention
the end
right things like fastest growing sport
or this that the other thing or like
it's it's a distraction i'm telling you
this is why i have a lot of gray hairs
i'm very clear on this
what your product your business right
what do you need to do you need to get
more people to know about it more people
that buy it more people to try it and
there really should be no other
conversation about anything about
anything else
how many tick tocks are is the brand
doing a day
depends up to ten some days one
interesting so we we
doubled our account in one month for
from 48 000 to 110 now you should be
spending like and obviously max has
lived this life like you should be
obsessed with tick tock everybody here
but you for sure should be obsessed yeah
but tick tock because it's going to go
away in 24 months
yeah what i mean by that is he's not
going to go away
good good all right so what else can i
answer what can i answer for you
i mean one big question
as you were saying we want to get it out
there more like how to sign content
great
alien styles how to get to reach out to
them and get them for
two ways one
make so much content and let the ground
swell of just normal organic growth
pressure them in
to hire four interns and pay the minimum
wage and let them dm people from the
account 24 hours a day
yeah
the great thing is your product is so
easy to ship it's lightweight you sent
me three of them they're fantastic my
kids love them so take advantage of
being able to ship them to the
influencers for sure
yeah so we've been doing that the thing
is that the hard part is to get through
to the a-listers
um you're not gonna you're not which is
actually the punch line of the question
because it's hard
yeah it's not gonna happen
unless it's naturally gonna happen yeah
got it so
there's no secret there's luck timing
and lots of effort
yeah
okay
like for example we also like give me
two minutes sure yeah so for example we
did a collaboration with john terry
former uh football player in england yep
and that was through like a back door
kind of thing it just happened as you
said
i could tell you right now you could do
something with cristiano ronaldo and
it's less important than you dominating
tick-tock
how
because tick-tock is a much more scaled
arbitrage than the most famous
footballer in the world but what if we
use his content on tick tock and just
push it
how are you going to do that
we pay for the rights as well
you're not going to do it is what i mean
because it's hard to reach
bingo yeah
you i'm telling you right now i smelled
it from a mile away i can smell it
because i'm old now
you got to get out of what you'd like to
happen and just keep executing on
everything you can control
yeah
got it
yeah we are
no i know you are the problem is your
energy is spending too much time on the
other thing i want you to be 110 on this
[ __ ] every footballer [ __ ] the olympics
[ __ ] gary vee [ __ ] everything tick-tock
yeah and what i mean by that when i say
tick-tock is of course a lot of other
things as well make content distribute
content lead people into your world
youtube shorts
yeah twitter reply start a discord
because now that's becoming a thing and
build a community execute
do you know why i'm unstoppable
because i only control what i can
control and don't care about all the
things i want
yeah
you guys are in full cliche three years
in winning
winning but too much of your collective
energy is focused on what you wish would
happen
versus just focusing 24 hours a day on
executing what you can control while
the number one thing that could ever
happen to you happened which is there's
a platform called tick tock that has so
much organic reach yeah
that if you just become the best in the
world at that and you have a product
that is made perfect for it
it will outperform anything and
everything else you spend your time on
all right let's skip ahead cool
let's go ahead and we're going to bring
on marcel
here we go marcel
how's it going marcel it's going good
what am i doing later unmute myself i
have unmuted all right
cool so
so my stable table is what i call it
it's got four stable uh table legs that
hydration exercise nutritious meals and
quality sleep
um
i'm just i've literally been practicing
this sort of um
methodology if you will for for 27 years
myself
and i've helped a lot of people
implement it
i really like teaching it to kids
because what i found
comes from
this is so much more than just like
being
you know hydrated on a daily basis or
choosing to be outside for 10 minutes
you know in the sunshine if you can and
and being conscientious about your your
food and some sleep hacks
um it it develops as self-care this i'm
very contextualized in this marcel yeah
so like i'm a buyer go ahead like to
maximize time what do you think what
what can i help with because i get it
for real
yeah it's legit like it's such great
stuff and i love that you said wide net
because i don't want to be really
focused on a certain
group or demographic because because in
theory the product and the project and
the concept and the hypothesis is for
everyone on earth applies to everyone so
what are you selling
um well that's the thing i escaped
you're not you're not sure right yeah
because i for me it's the it's the
knowledge i want people to live a better
life and and to be able to reap
uh the benefits of what i've done for
money's let me tell you what is probably
going to come up when we talk to paul
based on the quick interaction i had
with him the answer to your question is
you need to figure out two things the
version
that is altruistic you want the world to
be better right so this is the garyvee
model like 100 you know like you put out
you've got to put out that con the
answer to your question on that is
content in all platforms
and then what you have to decide is how
because you want to pay your bills and
live your life and you have you're
entitled to that what and how do you
sell
right
the container
and
like paul's done there's ways to create
a
premium version of a community for more
education and more access to you
right yep so there's that there's what
joe dispenza does which is events right
it's like an escapism like you go so
there's event marketing there's content
marketing that you charge for there's a
creating a consumer product right
all that energy might go into a loose
leaf tea that represents the whole thing
who knows but it's either product
pay for digital access pay for physical
access those are the three things you
have to figure out
yeah so i i've looked at an online
course i have basically developed
there's guides there's i'm i'm thinking
about the texting community if there's
something you can do on a daily kind of
push-up
um one day
can i give you a big piece of advice
because i've seen this story a million
times please
pick one and try
run it the number one thing i see marcel
over and over with this when people you
know obviously because i wrote crush it
in 2009 this was a big part i've seen
this over the last 15 years
pick one
and try
and take it from there uh mike vicanti
my trainer before he was my full-time
trainer had a virtual you know
coaching business and he didn't it was
great he had 150 clients and it was a
lot of work and he was getting paid it
was perfect and then one day he's like i
don't want to do this anymore
and we're working on i was like all
right mike a lot of people are relying
on you make sure you give them at least
a three month notice before you cancel
it
and he did and why am i saying that
whether your destiny is to start a
bottled water brand whether your destiny
is to do virtual coaching or patreon
whether your destiny is to do a physical
event twice a year that people pay for
you can change your mind along the way
which uncripples people from picking one
sure
sure
yeah i appreciate that um
i guess what i've looked at more closely
lately because i like the children's is
a children's book but with a set of like
a team of mascots um i know you've gone
big on that and and as soon as the
friends came out i was like oh this is i
can see a book with should empathy
elephant and you know patient panda and
they're talking about hydration and then
i mean i would love i mean i would push
you so hard to consider doing that in
your world create your create your v
friends your mickey mouse your like i
think that's a great idea but i think i
think the thing you have to ask yourself
is how do you want to monetize it if
we're talking under the context of
business
how to help the world that's just free
content at scale on tick tock and
instagram and twitter
sure whether it's merch or ip stuff or
whether it's a journal or a or an online
course like like i said for pure
simplicity because i want you to like
kind of leave here with value when you
leave this you say okay
am i gonna charge people for
digital access to me pay me nine bucks a
month to be on a tech service pay me 15
a month to be part of my three zooms for
an hour a month the virtual am i gonna
charge people for the physical version
am i gonna just put out a bunch of free
content and once every 90 days there's
an escape retreat with me and you pay
900 ahead 500 ahead so the physical one
or am i going to sell a physical product
merch loose leaf tea
meditation journal so
you as a personal brand that wants to
talk about a subject matter to monetize
have to decide of one of those three
and by the way you could do all three
eventually but i would pick one to start
with
got it that's awesome thank you awesome
let's move
you're on me brother
sorry rookie mistake we're gonna go over
to john b uh let me move here and john
you're up
right
now
okay thank you
um
so gary real estate brokerages are
becoming commoditized yes barriers to
entry are low correct how can we truly
stand out and differentiate ourselves
the same way they did even when they
weren't commoditized
brand
all that remax
and
sotheby's and keller williams all just
brand
when when
this has been my hypothesis about the
world almost everything's going to be
commoditized because of technology
and so the only thing left is brand
and how about for like a you know a
relatively small operation
you you you know i don't know if you've
ever heard of local celebrities
but you know wine library when i was
building it for my dad was really trying
to just do business in a 40-mile radius
and we were just famous in a 40-mile
radius i actually like it even more
brother
i wish
a lot of times that that was still my
life because micro targeting adds to a
40 mile radius is an unstoppable game
because then you're also making content
like hey you know i'll use new jersey
because i know it hey milburn new jersey
residents come and hang out with me at
the melbourne delhi from one to two and
i'll teach you about education i'll see
you and like running that ad on facebook
and instagram i mean you just become a
community juggernaut
you become the digital mayor of the
footprint
that you're trying to do business in
okay it's just the digital version of
bench ads and billboards and direct mail
you know
right right
so um
one of the most important things that we
have in our business is recruiting and
retention of agents they're all you know
they're all independent contractors that
can walk across i know it know it well i
know what sort of um
uh i'll give you an answer
it's not a social media strategy it's
actually an hr strategy the number one
way you'll win because you know when my
sister decided to go into real estate
i've always thought and because i've
been like such a public speaker in the
space for a long time and because i
think it's completely commoditized i've
often flirted in my head of like [ __ ] it
i'm just gonna create vayner realty and
put everybody out of business and when
when i've thought about it the way i'm
think about it is
the way you get recruitment is through
retention and the way you get retention
is
actually building a family no different
joe how long you been here
nine years almost james
seven and a half
like that's on when i they'll tell you
and then we've got [ __ ] 100 of them
that look like these two wonderful men
it is unfucking heard of in adland
unheard of
18 months 24 months and it's because i
care about them there's really nothing
else to say joe you can john excuse me
you can win this game jon the way you
win the game and i see it because i'm
very close to the brokerage game
is you got to give a better financial
incentive slightly
that's caring about them and then you
got to actually just build a family and
then recruitment will come through word
of mouth in the localization
you can run ads you can get new people
but the way you have to be obsessed with
keeping people and there's only two ways
you can keep them
emotionally is number one
and financially is number two and
everybody thinks financially is number
one
and they barely even think about
emotionally for real they say it john
they say it
but they don't [ __ ] mean it
and i'm telling you right now the way to
break the whole mortgage uh real estate
brokerage game is to actually mean it
what that you actually give a [ __ ] about
and it's like it's the company picnic
it's when they're struggling at home
sending flowers it's like being a mensch
being a good [ __ ] human being
i'm telling you it's it's so there for
the taking so just becoming obsessed
with being like the best leader and
creating some financial
aspects that is at least on par
it maybe you create some cool trigger
where it's bonus on performance in a way
that's more aggressive than the market
but
you're absolutely right it is the most
commoditized thing which is why like i'm
excited about the space i don't think
i'll get to it i have too many fish to
fry but it always felt like a space i
could do damage in because i knew it was
completely based on culture of how you
care about your people and a slightly
interesting financial tweak that if they
were a real killer i wanted them to eat
a little bit more of the monies
and then i think you could just kill it
very good um so again going back to the
fact they're all independent contractors
um so
you know we'll teach people how to do
things but when they go out on a listing
appointment they're all doing it kind of
their own way
is that is that bad and if so how do we
how do we standardize the process um
it's it can be bad it doesn't have to be
bad but i've got a different point of
view on this i think you and your
brokerage has to do so much heavy
marketing yourself
that that becomes the energy that they
all kind of osmosis to versus trying to
get them
streamlined on
okay cool thanks gary of course brother
that was a fun one for me as you can
tell john i've given a lot of time to
this space
i don't know if you sensed it but the
clarity of the advice i just gave you on
this stuff is like true conviction i
know it will work
mainly because i've said it enough times
kind of at keynotes and podcasts and
have received thousands of emails
especially on that family part i'm
telling you the way you acquire new
agents is retaining the ones you have
the way you retain the ones you have is
you got to like them a lot more no
matter how much you love them love them
more and come up with some sort of
financial trigger if they crush
yeah cool thank you you got it thanks
john
so now we are going to move our way over
to paul
oh give me a second i'll pull you up
here
here we go paul
gary just wanted to start off my time by
uh thanking you for the incredible
education i've received from your
content last four years you know what
you've shared has been far greater than
any teacher professor university uh
could provide it's not even close and
the best part about it uh now is i can
bond with my uh four-year-old daughter
of the v friends music she's absolutely
learning um to put patience and the
other traits i love it
thank you brother and lastly lastly i
rep the stripes um i'm the biggest
supporter of the zebras being a
basketball official so of course i'm a
zestful zebra i love that so yeah it's
wrong
i can't wait brother um yeah so i mean i
started patreon and discord um
in in july and it's been a great amazing
year i've connected with i have 134
people signed up um
yeah i'm super if it stops today i'm
super happy like i guess this is my
third one what do they pay
i have a seven dollar tier 15 tier and a
25 tier which gets you access to all of
our live sessions and that's the per
month right that's per month yeah and
where's the acquisition coming from
where is my acquisition of new people
mm-hmm like we're where are you getting
the customers from now at this point you
think just all the the content i put out
i've built
and where are we on tick tock because
you know i'm obsessed yeah sure i was at
6 50 in december and then i finally got
a bunch of mic'd up content that i was
sitting on that i knew i was going to do
really well and it it blossomed to 30k
um in like a week two weeks and how much
are you putting out right now
right now i'm back on a new wave last
four days i've put out probably 11 12
i'm trying to get to three or four a day
and i'm getting ready to uh film this
weekend
can you add one tick tock a day that is
less
you educating and being the guy and more
like you the human being
okay uh with regards to officiating or
off the court stuff off the court stuff
like drinking orange juice i like orange
like
one of the things that people
struggle with in the transition to
tick-tock is really making tick-tocks
right
and that's what i paused on the the
platform for a while i didn't know where
my my space was
which is
you'll never believe this is for
everybody pay attention your space is to
just make anything guys gals tick tock
is crazy
it's based on the interest graph i'll
give you an example
you as a basketball referee to not make
a tick tock last night or first thing
this morning without knowing your
sleeping habits about the nba finals
last night and anything anything
hey guys
it's paul let me tell you why marcus
smart really matters
that's it
it'll get your output up it'll round out
your person think about how unique i am
everybody here right now think about how
many different things you know about me
like my interests whether it's football
or wine or garage like i've
i'm rounded out and everyone's playing a
role i want you to be rounded out within
your world
so like you i want you to talk about
anything but for i'll give you a great
example i think you could i know this
for fact
if you really start consuming tick tock
for a month and get what's going on
there
you'll make a video about why dads and
moms should start making their
five-year-old work their left hand or
right if they're a lefty
and like just make some sort of random
ass video of like why most people never
develop the other hand and that video
will get 1.9 million views because it's
just a like parents like oh man and like
that ended up getting you 25 people to
patreon
not even talking about reffing talking
about a school they know
they know you're a ref
because all your other content and your
bio and url is reffing people go too
literal with their content
right for example even max who's crushed
4 million if i looked under the hood
he's got his formula clearly it's worked
but if he just does something random
left field
about like skiing
that
matters and nobody does that
everyone's in their box
yeah
you got you how many of you here know
that i love blueberries
point made got it my blueberry video of
me loving blueberries in that green room
is my most viewed instagram of all time
got it so just that's what one point and
again i'm gonna pound all of you even
one year from launching
a t
tick-tock is a moment in time that will
go away
in four years everyone's gonna be making
i'm gonna be making videos saying sorry
it's over you can't make a left-handed
dribbling video and get a million views
james orsini can't make a view a video
about new jersey blue claw club like
it's it's the organic reach is going to
go away and the way that max doing
everything he did to go from zero to
four million
if he did it exactly the same starting
2024 to 2026 is gonna have 17 000
followers not four million
this is what always happens which is why
you can imagine why i'm stressing
because i know the doors now i know
we're at halftime a lot of you follow me
i've been saying this for four [ __ ]
years
the door is closing and all of you will
regret not squeezing it no matter even
if you crush it because i live it so i
know what max is about to do max is
gonna have seven million and he's gonna
wake up when it's over and they're gonna
look at each other so they're gonna be
like [ __ ] i wish we made six tick tocks
a day back then
oh we've got we've got 90 seconds left i
want you to make sure you talk about the
abuse and officiating thing oh i saw
that email you told me i think that
could be an important topic but let's
let's hash it out
yeah one other play about you know me
trying to have impact is the industry is
is reaching a nat experience in a
national shortage of officials due to
physical and verbal abuse so i want to
um and i'm and now with my tic toc
content i'm starting to inspire
non-officials to become officials it's
my favorite part it's my favorite part
of what you're doing
so gary
can i go deeper into this and really
senate what what would what would your
suggestion be to inspire more officials
what channels campaigns would you do to
get people to want to talk
tick-tock
i'm telling you brother with all my
heart
may come make hey here's your video hey
do you love basketball but you work at
target
did you know that you should be an
official
and make that video 700 times 700
different ways
okay think about all the people that
have lower paying jobs
that may consider this as a full-time
profession or here's a different version
of that hey are you a high-powered
lawyer but you need some escapism you
should be an official on the side
you see where i'm going yeah because i i
think if i can be the reason why i uh
people get into the profession then the
men i mean the mentor group is is gonna
you'll explain
you're exactly right okay one more yeah
ten seconds i'm on episode 259 of my
podcast i would love to get you on
episode 305 for either three minutes and
five seconds or 30 minutes and 50
seconds your choice three episode 355
for five minutes done got it thank you
bro
yeah write that down hold on 355 five
minutes joe
that's right thank you all right
all right cool we're gonna go to the
last but not least max and sophia so um
pulling you guys up on stage here
and there we go go ahead guys
hey gary uh yeah again so great to be
here uh so in terms of our business
currently we make money primarily
through brand deals totally out of
necessity um you know don't don't really
love it but
um we are interested in turning this you
know social media presence into a more
sustainable long-term
uh vision so there's two things that
we're working on one we're launching a
cpg brand in four months right something
i've been
totally passionate about for 10 years
some super pumped that is finally coming
together direct to consumer
direct to consumer to start yeah
um
yep and then the next is we're really
interested in launching an nft
we've been watching
everything happen
um
but
narrowing down the utility is the big
question mark
it's so important
i mean the big one is personal cooking
lessons from you
yeah that's that's number two on my list
that i was that i can share um
my thing on that is you know scaling
scaling the unscalable is always the
most valuable
live streaming to everybody is very
different than a group of six
and the top tier the gold being one on
one physically
right so that was part of my question
and how to format this nft like do you
do you try to do 10 000 that of course
you'll never sell ten thousand the
market's super suppressed the gold rush
is over you don't have
ten thousand people or five seven
thousand like the you won't sell that
i think first of all you gotta really
ask yourself if you want to do an nft
because the market is now very hard
right second if you decide to do it
someone like you with that kind of reach
my intuition
is you do
500 to a thousand and you break them
into three tiers the scaled the
different than what you do with live
streams extra special version of that
for four thousand
nine hundred people get the six person
cooking class and one person or ten
people get the one on one depending on
how hard you wanna hustle
but the answer to your question on an
nft project is access to you
access right that's the leverage you
have right now you have a fan base
in two years if the consumer brand is
good and it could be that there could be
some other stuff but that is where your
leverage sits
what are your thoughts on because i know
you had the book games and did that very
successfully combining the physical
product with an nft type strategy
whether it's a pre-sale three years i'm
very into it the problem is is that
book games worked because that was 16
years of community building
you know everyone's like gary of course
feed friends worked like you already had
a big audience i'm like i earned that
audience
right and as you know
even if you think about how everyone was
talking here you included
my following
is different than a lot of people's
following because of the value exchange
that people get out of me which creates
a very different relationship than if
someone's attractive or even something
as cool as learning to cook
that's not going to carry as much weight
as somebody with
a following where you've changed their
mental or financial life it's just not
going to be as deep it just can't
no different i mean i lived it i was a
monster star in wine but that community
wasn't as deep as the people that i've
changed their financial or emotional
life right
so even though you have this big number
you have to be careful of because it's a
tremendous i mean i view cooking similar
to sports and music it's a big genre
you just don't know how deep it goes to
what they really want
right that's the core thing what do they
really want and what's going to
hold values
what they want for sure is access to you
and
for sure
with me i'm such a successful 25-year
businessman that people think they're
going to make money on it they wouldn't
think that with you
in terms of investing in it and it goes
up in value right
i have a big advantage because i've been
such a business winner and then in the
first year it proved out and so now it's
like [ __ ] cat out of the bag right
yeah i mean why do you think everybody
bought book games because 99 of people
regretted not buying series one v
friends
exactly
that's right
you know so
so
you know you got to keep that in mind
right
okay yeah that's a huge takeaway um
i saw you guys up in this top screen
like you also heard me on the tick tock
part around that like round out your
world a little bit
yeah that's one thing where we're very
focused on like set perfect content
correct because because and especially
because it's worked you're double [ __ ]
because you have your system and it
works right but what you're leaving out
is the expansion
do you know many people like me because
of wine and the new york jets only
a lot
yeah so show the world who you are
completely are you into comic books are
you into sports are you into music you
gotta like make you've got and it won't
do as well at first and it will be hard
to be disciplined but i'm telling you it
will work out
[Music]
so on that topic of like diversifying
myself as we create this new brand like
i guess for just more clarity we're four
months out from from having this
and
where your brain just went now is ore
how many tick tocks a day
currently yeah
about one a day beautiful so you know
we've got the room
uh you could go to three a day
by doing your core thing which probably
takes time right which is why you're
only doing one
you can do one for the cpg brand
and you can do one
of course and you can do one
every couple days on some random ass
[ __ ]
like you're the biggest closet seinfeld
fan
why everyone loses is they become
obsessed with the system the algorithm
and production
right
this should land with you if you're as
close to what i do you know this will
work
there is no set thing with me it can
come from any angle it can be produced
it could be [ __ ]
me with bad i've got the do many people
email me like gary the [ __ ] sun was
on the other side if you just turned
around do you know how much better the
video would have looked i'm like okay
like it doesn't [ __ ] matter is that
he-man
let's go marcel um
uh so max like and by the way actually
that was so meta right like think about
that
that just stopped me in my tracks he-man
right like you need to widen out who you
are to your audience you could then go
much much further
um okay so if you were in my position
and you were about to launch a product
would you
is the and component you would start a
new tick tock for that brand yes and
basically just cross pollinate all the
content
post one
i wouldn't post the same thing
per se i would do it occasionally
but you've got a huge audience on your
on your main one so you're gonna have to
play that out but you got to build up
the other one because it's because it
has to exist even though wine library
and vayner x and v friends are all much
smaller platforms than garyvee they all
exist and do their thing
and part of what you've been talking
about is you're like the everyman of the
the grilling universe so that everything
that's what i did with wine library tv
but you just need to you need to get
them to love you more and right now
you're not showing them enough of you
right
it's interesting i think that's going to
be my biggest takeaway and i didn't have
any thought that that would be we would
even enter that subject but that is
clearly my weakness like everything is
so focused and
has to be perfect and i know you say
it's you know perfection perfection is
you know and you're in a double bad spot
because a lot of people do that out of
insecurity your double bad spot is
predicated on the fact that it's working
and now you have to deploy humility to
not see a million views you have to be
okay with 9 000 views because those 9
000 views they're gonna love you because
you like metallica like them
i want people to know me
for my favorite fruit of choice by the
way just so everybody hears this as you
all know i'm hyper private personally
you share what you want to share but
share things
that doesn't mean share like your
personal life like i don't do that as
you i'm sure all very much know but on
the flip side blueberries and root beer
and wine and the jets and the knicks and
garage sales get that into the eco world
even like i bet you a lot of people are
i'm curious off just a little bit five
seconds in to know what your favorite
cereal is
i actually recreated cinnamon toast
crunch for a video i made giant cinnamon
toast crunch soda there it is
[Music]
you